well you have a very cerebral way of
thinking about these things and i don't
know if you do it retrospectively like
if we look back at the younger
tom cavanaugh and go no he was
pissed
the girl he was dating or was his wife
at the time whatever was she like oh my
god remember how upset you are you're
smoking pot constantly you were drinking
a bunch of
you were you getting and now you look at
you and you're like yeah was it the same
mentality or was there a part of that
where you're
like flipping out i think that it was
less
you know i'd hollered how less pot
smoking less drinking
it was it was just a lot it was a lot
more heartbreak
yeah it was like that was the thing
mostly it wasn't so much like
you guys it was more like i
really like
because you know how it is i really like
acting with you
and i'm hoping that we can do this for a
long time yeah and then it gets
yanked away yeah and part of the reason
it makes it so special acting with you
is because i know it can be yanked away
and
what you hope is that it won't be yanked
away and when it does get yanked away
even though hey we gotta get together
hey we gotta that never happens if
you're fortunate you take one or two
people from
each show and you stay with them but
your intense your intentions are great
but everyone else has to go
make a living try and find another job
and go on and
and do that and so there's heartbreak
because the reality is
the thing that you love and the people
that you love you're just not going to
see them anymore and that was
that's the biggest thing the other thing
is
and this is the silver lining or the the
golden part of it is like you know what
that's that door closing is all right
what what what am i going to do next
like what
what could come next well you know
something that uh look at the flash i
mean for instance i mean how many years
since you came on i mean you came in six
years ago
yeah you didn't think you were gonna
even be on the series that long right it
was just
like a introduction of a character did
you think you were going to be on this
long no of course not
oh no it's interesting you know that i
didn't know that you knew that but yeah
like there was
it felt like after season one it was
flash versus reverse flash and
i thought that this is just and again
i know i'm talking about myself so much
but greg berlanti who's like hollywood's
golden boy uber producer he's just
tremendous he's one of the great human
beings that i've ever worked with
you know i remember like bill lawrence
michael roush rob burnett
these guys are show runners of shows
that i've done and i've been really
fortunate to work with people who are
like
great humans like they're intelligent
they're smart they have perspective
bill lawrence is one of the guys who his
little quote was that
you can't take it personally you know um
scrubs right he was one of the creators
you're the guy that did like spin city
and scrubs and he's like they're not
going to put the show on his thing you
can never take it personally
and you you pick up stuff like that and
so
you know greg is uh
is so impressive because of his
integrity and i think most people who
work on his shows can go like yeah
it's rare that you meet someone who's so
committed to
doing the right thing and back a long
time ago you know
um there was a couple of things i went
in for a show
of his and uh he wanted me for one of
the leads and i
didn't do it and i thought well that'll
be it that'll be it for him and i
and he he said well his as i walked out
after saying no his words he's like well
i'm not going anywhere
meaning he's going to be around and do
other shows but i was like
that'll be it because i didn't do this
show and then
a little while later he did the show
called jack and bobby which lasted a
season
and called me up and said hey do you
want to play this guy who rages it that
rages at the moon he's got like a
looks like a drug problem or an alcohol
problem and like he's got more things
going on than that
complicated character and um
wait no that was eli stone sorry jack
and bobby was a
gay cocaine addicted brother to
christine lottie and
you know at the time people like tom's a
nice guy so but greg would pick me for
these like challenging
roles and offered that to me and i was
like this is
an honor to have him think that i could
do this and that show only lasted a year
and then the next one the guy raging at
the moon was eli stone
again he called and it's one of those
guys who
it's stunning to get a call in your
corner everyone needs that guy he's just
always been in your corner he always
sees
he sees it so rare yeah rare so rare
yeah
so rare as you know because once they've
done one thing with you they're like
that's it
you